[Musique]
/
je vous remercie d'avoir vous libérer
pour participer à cette matinée notre
ambition dans le cadre de la mission
c'est vraiment de pouvoir faire une
analyse objective
cearense afin de pouvoir donc exprimé un
certain nombre de recommandations qui
doivent aller dans le sens positif pour
chacun l'intérêt pour un parlementaire
pour nous en particulier de la mission
s'est véritablement d'être au plus près
de la réalité des choses ça c'est
fondamental pourrait pas construire
un projet un rapport ou des
préconisations
si on n'est pas dans la connaissance
parfaite du terrain donc les
déplacements pour aller au poste et en
revenir s'effectueront à pied arbres
cassés ou culasse ouvertes et dans tous
les cas totalement vide rien dans les
chargeurs rien dans les arbres semblait
important voire indispensable de pouvoir
montrer aux sénateurs c'est un petit peu
une commande delà de leur part 2 qu'est
ce qu'une une vraie chasse collective au
grand gibier comment est-ce que s'est
organisée
si jean maitron joue de l'animal eh ben
je le ferai je ne mettrai à jour qu'à
partir de cet angle je ne le mettrai
jamais en jeu ici et je n'ai pas le
droit de te tirer dans cette quand on
voit aujourd'hui comment s'est organisé
on a du mal à imaginer qu'il puisse y
avoir des accidents après on n'est pas à
l'abri d'avoir
quelqu'un qui trébuche mais c'est vrai
que c'est très organisés c'est très
cadrée et on va essayer de comprendre y
compris on va aller voir aussi des
victimes je pense
d'accidents de chasse essayer de
comprendre dans quel contexte ces
accidents ont pu avoir
les sangliers ont été plus malins que
les chasseurs mais ça ça arrive souvent
on n'a pas pu avoir sur la ligne le trac
on n'a pas pu les en chasser mais voilà
c'était important de montrer comment
comment ça se passe vraiment la
précision c'est quelque chose de
fondamental ou tirer aujourd'hui en
action de chasse beaucoup plus de balles
que vous lui prélever d'animaux
ça veut dire qu'il ya beaucoup de
boiseries sont des balles vite perdu et
on va limiter le nombre de balles tirées
en augmentant la précision plus
statistiquement on va augmenter la
sécurité à l'afp on peut tomber de vélo
quand on fait du vélo là on ne peut pas
avoir une balle qui se passe c'est pas
possible c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
vraiment donc écarter totalement est le
plus beau des dons que dès lors que le
risque existe on doit le stopper la
réflexion qu'on aura à mener c'est
comment fait-on qui engage ton pour
pouvoir se donner des certitudes sur le
respect des règles de sécurité